you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
get things done nobody gets it done like
we do you know I don't know are we
letting the media in is the media here I
guess we have a limited media because of
distancing and some people think I did
that on purpose
but we've been getting along with them
reasonably well lately I just want to
thank you all for coming back because
you came back this is a Republican group
largely if not in all cases
you know they look pretty Republican I'm
not sure about Devin let's just you know
this is a very very Republican group and
we appreciate you coming back i Debbie
and I just want to say a few words and
maybe we'll say a couple of words in
front of the media we just left the most
beautiful ceremony celebrating 75 years
of these 75 years and it was magnificent
it was beautiful it was windy and
beautiful and we have a great country
and we're rebuilding our country we had
the greatest economy of the history of
the world no country had anywhere near
us and we had the best we've ever had
but we've had the best ever in the world
China is a very good competitor but we
would do a much better than China and
that's before kovat before this plague
came in we were doing much much better
than anybody best we've ever done and we
had to close it down it was an
artificial closing we had to just close
it down never happened a thing like that
never happened before we did the right
thing it's horrible what's happened it
should have been stopped it should have
been stopped where it came from which
was China it could have been stopped
easily and quickly and for some reason
they were unable to do it I think they
tried but it got away from him I guess
but it's a shame and so many hundreds of
thousands of people around the world
have been killed 184 countries
but we're going to build our country
back and we're going to build it back
fast this group of people we all did it
before and we'll do it again we created
something that has never been seen
before and if you are somebody that
likes history and I think everyone in
this room likes history you wouldn't be
doing what you're doing you would see
that and you would remember that this
was the year that China was going to
overtake us in the economy if you go
back to much you would see that they
weren't anywhere close that we were
going to be there many years of a very
if the right person sits in this seat
it'll never happen the wrong person sits
in this seat it'll happen in a period of
a few years or less can happen almost
immediately so we are in a position
where we have to start all over again
and we will start all over again and
we'll build something that was even
better than we had before recognizing
that so many people have died so many
people have died that's the one thing we
can't do anything about unfortunately
what I can't say is if we did it the
different way if we went heard if we
just said let's wing it we would have
been talking about numbers that would
have been unsustainable and unacceptable
you look on the screens you look on
television today and you see body bags
and you see mass graves and we may be
talking about ninety five thousand
people ultimately we may be talking
about something more than that but if
you take a low number one and a half
million so you multiply whatever number
we're talking about times fifteen it
would not it would not be acceptable
what not it's not acceptable now one
person is an acceptable let alone
perhaps a hundred thousand so we're
going to rebuild it we're going to
rebuild it back as fast as we can I
think we're going to have any
we'll transition but transition leads to
fourth quarter third quarter I call it
transition we'll start to see it it's
already happening people want to come
back I think everybody in this room
realizes we have to come back otherwise
you have a broken country you'll never
be able to do it again you'll never be
able to build this miracle it's a
miracle what we did what all of us did
and what many people before us did
you'll never be able to build it again
the people want to come back you see
what's going on at state houses all over
the country they want to come back I
think some people don't want it really
to come back for political reasons which
is sick but the people the real people
the people that want this country to be
great and great again we can say they
want to get back and we're gonna have
embers we're gonna have fires we're
gonna have things to put out and we'll
put them out we learned a lot you know
things that we had no idea
two months ago we've learned a lot over
the last couple of months and we're
going to do a job like like nobody's
seen before and I spoke with Angela
Merkel today I spoke with Prime Minister
Abbey of Japan I spoke with many of the
leaders over the last four or five days
and so many of them almost all of them I
would say all of them not everybody
would want to admit it but they over
your says the world leader and they're
following us you look at what we've done
with ventilators we started we had no
ventilators nobody thought in terms of a
ventilator it's like and I say to all
the times like building a car and other
countries don't have ventilators and we
became so successful at ventilators and
building this very complex machine very
expensive machine but very very complex
to have it right to do it right highly
computerized very technologically
significant so we built and we built and
we built and they took other factories
factories for totally other purposes and
now we have nine factories that are
throwing out ventilators at numbers at
No
but he can believe it was really there's
not been anything like that since the
Second World War
well we did the same thing with other
types of product and we're giving
thousands and thousands away to other
countries that are people dying because
they don't have ventilators and they're
not equipped to do what we did so we're
giving thousands and thousands of these
ventilators away to many countries that
have suffered greatly Italy France Spain
so many countries and Nigeria called
tremendous problems in Nigeria
tremendous problems all over and so
they're very happy in addition to that
we're building stockpiles for ourselves
so this disaster ever happens again we
have plenty some of the governors were
working along great with almost all of
the governor's but some of them they
needed ventilators now it's testing and
we have testing at a level that nobody
has ever done before every leader tells
us the same thing in fact they want to
know what are we doing but you don't
hear that from the media you never hear
that but what's happened with testing is
incredible so as of this morning we've
done eight and a half million tests and
yesterday alone in one day we did three
hundred thousand tests and that's an
incredible tribute now they have the
test where it takes you five minutes
that was a test that didn't even exist
everything had to go to a lab it would
be sent to the lab so it takes a day and
then it takes another day but it takes
you three four or five days if they do a
good job now you do a test bump and you
have it in five minutes and nobody ever
thought a thing like that was even
possible
that's the Abbott Laboratories but now
we have other competitive tests even
with that so what we've done has been
incredible we're going to continue to do
it we go and we're going into transition
and I call it transition to greatness
it's going to be transition to greatness
because we're going to do something very
fast and we're going to have a
phenomenal year next year
third quarter transition fourth quarter
is going to be good this tremendous pent
up demand and next year we're going to
have a phenomenal year and with that I
think maybe I'd like to go around the
room and you
introduce yourself and say a few words
and then after that the media will leave
and we'll have some discussions among
ourselves ok please we start I think I
know this gentleman and by the way Kevin
has done some job he should have had
this job a long time before he had it
but that's ok we have we have a great
man and he's going to be hopefully a
great speaker in the house we got to get
him there we get him there and when I
say hopefully hopefully we're gonna win
because I have no doubt he'll be a great
speaker of the house would have to hope
about anything he's done a fantastic job
Kevin well mr. president I do want to
say one thing as you'd the first lady
were out there honoring what transpired
75 years ago that we had to end the
tyranny of what Hitler was doing
throughout Europe we now battle
something that is like a war then this
is a virus that came from a distant land
that we did not invite but just as we
had to transform our country then and
unite that leadership you're providing
is doing just that as you talk about
ventilators gearing up testing more than
1.7 million in one week the ingenuity of
this country will solve this problem
and we will not just solve and get a
vaccine for us but for the rest of the
world I do want to thank you I'm coming
from California I know I'm having a blue
state I know I have a governor but the
way you've worked together watching you
send those Navy ships to New York and to
California build those hospitals in the
time of need I do want to thank you on
behalf of all everyone in Calif
great state thank you very much police
Thank You mr. president for all the
support for New York State this has been
a true partnership in the administration
has stepped up whether its ventilators
or building the Javits Center which was
tremendously important my district in
upstate New York people are eager to get
back to work safely our tourist
businesses our hotels have been
devastated so as we talk about this
transition making sure that we allow
all businesses to get back to work
safely is so incredibly important also
our farmers thank you to secretary
Purdue for stepping up we have dairy
farmers in our district who are going
through a crisis but we know that you
support the farmers and we're
appreciative of all of your work for New
York and I know you've worked
effectively with Democrats and
Republicans in New York State so thank
you thank you very much and so for the
farmers you know we gave 12 billion
dollars two years ago from China through
tariffs because they were targeting our
farmers and then we gave 16 billion and
this year we're giving 19 billion to the
farmers and that's more money than
they've ever even thought about and it's
keeping them in a position where a
really a position of strength but they
deserve it what they've gone through for
18 19 years this isn't a new phenomena
this is four years they've been ripped
off so we're taking care of our farmers
thank you very much Alisa
dan please Thank You mr. president thank
you for having us here and thank you for
working every single day you know
speaker Pelosi would have though the
America believe that we can only show up
to Congress to vote effort once every
three weeks of course that's not true we
could be working every single day just
like this administration is and I
appreciate what you've done
appreciate working with us for to
protect our energy industry know America
is isn't as in real dire straits with
oil prices the way they are we're deeply
worried about that in Texas and our
administration's been excellent
to work with on that we understand how
important energy independence is to our
nation Texas is reopening and I think it
can be a model for the rest of the
country as we step out of a retreat and
move to actually confront this virus
head-on and get people back to work well
it's interesting too because oil prices
are now going up and gasoline prices are
going down that's like the best
combination I've ever heard so are
millions of people in the energy
business I think it's going to be you
know that's moving up but you look at
those gasoline prices and they're really
coming down so I don't think I've ever
seen a combination like that it's gonna
be very good a lot of good things
happening in energy Jared you should say
something because you headed up our
whole ventilator problem that this
country had we the cupboard was bare
when we took it over people don't
realize it they don't want to say
but the cupboard was bare that we had
nothing and I could say that for the
military to Dan would know that almost
better than anybody and the folks that
are so much and so well well-versed on
military but our military cupboard was
barrel so we had obsolete equipment we
had old equipment and now we have we've
never been in a position like this we
have the best equipment in the world all
made in the United States but Jared why
don't you give a little a little talk on
what we did with the ventilators and how
that just became such an incredible
story and we're doing the same thing
with testing and we're pretty close to a
point where were equally as good
balanced stockpile that the country has
continues to grow initially it was very
scary and that we had a lot of states
requesting numbers that could not be
supplied and a lot of you were very
helpful getting the local hospitals and
your districts to give the actual data
to the federal government because the
president wanted to make sure that
anybody in this country who needed a
ventilator would get a ventilator he saw
what's happening in Italy where people
were dying in hospitals and not able to
get the care they needed and the
president said I don't want that to
happen in America deploy every resource
that we have get all the Intel we have
and let's do our best to try to make it
work and we were able to make it work
thanks to your leadership and then what
we were also able to do is use the
defense production act at the
president's urging and we were able to
contract 11 different ventilator
companies last year America made about
30,000 ventilators this year will make
about 150,000 in a four month period and
so we're in a place right now where
we're doing well a lot of our allies the
countries that are friendly with America
are starting to get ventilators from us
and we have more than enough to take
care of all the American citizens so
it's been a great success story and on
testing the numbers continue to grow we
have all the supplies that we need to do
it we've now educated all the governors
we have over five thousand testing
machines in the city we've had the
commercial sector through the
public-private partnerships at the
president you know how to sleeve those
have now identified over 5,000 machines
we've done DPA on swabs so we're making
a ton of swabs we have reagents we have
transport media and we've been working
with all the governor's to help them
with the national guard on how to better
collect samples and so we're seeing
those numbers starting to really rise
and when you look at the number that
America's done relative to any other
country where 2 to 3 times the next the
next the next number so on an absolute
basis the job that you've led on that
has been absolutely tremendous and
that's giving the tools to America to
start opening up these counties and
allowing Americans to get back to work
Thank You Jerry you've done a great job
someday people are going to appreciate
us they say oh he's a relation well if
it wasn't a good relation I'd get him
out of here so fast sometimes we have a
problem Louis I said get Jared on it
great job here smart guy so here's
another smart guy so Devon I think I
thought about Devon more over the last
couple of days than anybody else because
this guy would come in and he'd tell
people what was going on and nobody
believed it because it was not
believable it wasn't true that they
would be doing a takeover of a
presidency illegally and all of the
illegality who was going on and he was
the first one our superstar Jim and all
of us will admit this guy was just he
wouldn't stop Devin Nunez he wouldn't
stop
he saw it before anybody and you deserve
a medal you deserve the equivalent of
Pulitzer Prizes they ought to take two
Pulitzer Prize away from all of these
phony journalists that got a Pulitzer
Prize and they they were wrong they were
wrong on everything and now they've been
proven wrong
I saw where clapper not a smart guy how
do you have not a smart person heading
up intelligence how does that work right
you have a man who is not smart and he
heads up intelligence and that's
possibly what happened they ran away
with it but but he knew what was going
on and I'd watch him on television he'd
say the worst things and now I know why
shifty shift dishonest corrupt
politician why this guy didn't want
these papers exposed because all these
people said under oath where they go to
jail if they lie they would totally know
I didn't see any collusion with Rush
nothing noise so I said but he was on
television before and after saying that
was massive collusion like Putin was my
best friend
we had no calls to Russia we had no
calls from Russia for years and all of a
sudden we have this great friendship and
by the way getting along with Russia is
a great thing getting along with Putin
and Russia's a great thing and stuff
like this makes it impossible and that
leads to very bad things very bad things
but I have to say that Devin was
incredible he understood it he
understood that it was a hoax before
anybody else knew what was happening and
then I have to say the people in this
room took over and did a hell of a job
with you right they had guts
they had guts like nobody has ever seen
before I want to thank you on behalf of
our country and I'd like to have you I
mean is to talk a little bit about the
situation our country's in now I know
you're well aware we've had six seven
weeks here of keeping people inside
their homes we've learned a lot about
this virus there's still a lot more we
need to learn we need to learn what our
friends over in Asia we're doing the
time that this virus was taking off and
issues with the World Health
Organization and I believe with your new
pick with John Ratcliffe a member of the
House Intelligence Committee member from
Texas he's going to do a great job
getting to the bottom of this and I
think leading the intelligence agencies
through some would have been some pretty
dark times over the last few years and
and I think we should say Rick Grinnell
has done a great job
in fact John called up John Radcliffe
called up two days ago he said you know
I'm really looking forward this but I
don't know if I can top the guy we have
in there right now and he was he's gonna
do a phenomenal job but Rick Grinnell
has has been incredible before that we
had an empty seat
we had an empty seat but Rick Grinnell
what he's done
even Louie would admit that and I saw a
Rick yesterday walking in with thousands
of pages of paper into the Justice
Department we didn't see that before did
we Louie huh
Rick Grinnell did a great job and John
is gonna be phenomenal
please mr. president what we expect and
the American people expect is
transparency from our law enforcement
agencies and I think we're well on our
way to getting that I want to also thank
you for bringing us back here to show
the American People that we could be
here and do our work
the Democrats are cowering at home right
now and it makes no sense because we've
learned so much I can understand for the
first few weeks but we're learning we
have ventilators we have we're learning
new ways how to treat this virus and if
we're expecting as you know you've been
in my district it's a the San Joaquin
Valley of California a heavy
agricultural area my folks have been
going to work my folks have been going
to work and because they have to feed
this country a lot along with a lot of
folks around here and you know if we
expect the guys that are that are
cutting meat or working in a grocery
store working these packing plants if we
expect them to go to work we have to go
to work as members of Congress I will
say I get you all of your permits
necessary from the federal government
for water you know we throw millions of
gallons a day of water into the Pacific
Ocean that comes from up north and when
I saw Devon I say how come those fields
are all barren they're beautiful land o
barren brown and then they'll have a
little patch like this a little patch in
a corner or a little patch on one side
and it's beautiful green you could see
it with soap Edison
so much of a 90% 95% it looks like a
desert and you have this he said we
don't have water I said you mean you
have a drought it's a long time ago we
met right right at the beginning before
I got elected and I said you mean you
have a drought he said no we'd have a
drought we send millions of gallons of
water out to the ocean
to protect a very well I've never seen
anything so important I think
everything's important to protect go
ahead what's the name the smell delta
smelt so you have a delta smelt that's
not doing well it's getting no water and
it will do a lot better if it had water
but they send millions and millions of
is that seriously is that the only
reason that's the reason they send it
out there yeah about it for the deltas I
didn't say yes it's your armors are very
thankful for for recognizing the
important work that you've done not only
in San Joaquin Valley but all over the
country and I'll just say that's why
we're out working and I think we should
be working what you know right with with
the water though I said so what has to
happen when you need approvals from
Congress from this for that you need all
sorts of the risk but you need from
commerce more importantly than anything
I got every approval for you and you get
a lot of the state approvals done
through Kevin and yourself and others
all you need now is the signature of the
governor and those millions of gallons
of wasted order going into the Pacific
that's like a drop in the bucket doesn't
mean anything to the Pacific all of that
water would come right down all the way
into Los Angeles and you know in Los
Angeles I had a house in Los Angeles you
couldn't I sold it you know why I sold
it because Secret Service says you can't
come here anymore I said I might as well
sell it but I had a house and you
couldn't you couldn't have water you
couldn't water your grass they said oh
you're not allowed to what are you grass
and then you look at this massive turn
they had a turn it tooks it takes a day
to turn it's like a big faucet and they
turn it and it veers all the water out
into the Pacific it's crazy so we're all
set except you need Gavin's signature
Gavan signature you can have water from
Los Angeles all the way up and it's the
most incredible thing I've ever seen
that I think I thought it was a drought
I said you missed he said no we have
tremendous amounts of water but we send
it out to the Pacific Ocean
and it was over the smelt so if you can
get his signature I know I know you know
during this time the crisis we need to
work with the governor and I thank you
for working with our governor it was
obviously not a supporter of yours but
there is a serious issue there that the
govern is to recognize that we have a
water crisis in our in our state that
you've recognized and he needs to drop
the lawsuits that he's we've gotten
along very well gavin newsom we've got
on very well with regard to Cove in
nineteen as we call it in that respect
he's been fantastic and we've been
fantastic and he said very generous
things but on other things we disagree
like the water like cars because you can
have a car for much less money that's
equally good environmentally but much
safer better better car california it
forces you to build a bad car that
doesn't work well and there are a lot of
reasons for not doing it that way so
we'll end up so on that we don't agree
but we agree on we agree on the
coronavirus and when that we get along
very well and we've done a great job for
California and for everybody and and he
was very honest about that assessment it
would be great if you could get the
water but you're all set okay you're all
set just I say that to Kevin to get his
signature and you you're gonna have so
many you can all those thousands of
acres are gonna be opened up and they'll
have plenty of water for Los Angeles too
so they won't have to rash and they're
gonna water they're gonna ration the
water in California it's the most
incredible thing I've ever seen and yet
they're sending millions of gallons out
so thank you very much but thank you for
thank you very much for the job you've
done
appreciate it an expert please Ted but
North Carolina thank you for having me
here I also want to thank my colleagues
from the house
there is no vote today
there's nothing we're voting on the
speaker speaker Pelosi has not brought
us in to do anything meaningful but
we're here to lead by example and to say
that we're ready to work so we need
something meaningful to help those back
home in North Carolina we're very
grateful for all the work that you've
done here and again Secretary of
minuchin want to thank you as well for
all that you've done the PPP and the
work that you've done for Main Street
has helped to keep these businesses
intact so that we can have intact so
that we can have this quick recovery
we're ready for q3 we're ready to get
going in North Carolina we're ready to
rebuild for holding China accountable I
think for waiting long no one's held
accountable and the fact that we're
looking into the World Health
Organization and how they really work in
glove with the Chinese Communist Party
to cover this virus up and in early days
absolutely absolutely shameful so thank
you for bringing attention to that in
Pennsylvania we're having a really hard
time because the governor is at such
draconian shut down measures we're now
number one in unemployment claims but
we're only number five in terms of
population instead of protecting the
most vulnerable and nursing homes which
where you had 65 percent of the deaths
have not more in Pennsylvania he just
had a Turco nion measure
one-size-fits-all crude approach I lack
any kind of nuance and it's destroying
our economy well at the same time
leaving those vulnerable exposing this
virus so thanks for calling out the
governor's that are going too far with
this and pulling for America and
Congress to go back to work so what the
Democrats are doing in Pennsylvania is a
disgrace okay it's a disgrace
thank you very much mr. president
mark Greene from Tennessee great to see
you again this thanks for your
leadership this Co good night thank 19
thing has been unprecedented
you know it's a challenge to both the
world and the United States our country
a China made a challenge made worse by
China and the delays and information to
us the deception in China lied and and
people died and as an infantry officer
ER physician former business CEO I know
that when a leader is caught in an
ambush that leader has to make
split-second decisions with the
information that they have
mr. president I'm proud but the
decisions that you have made decisions
like banning travel from China which
these guys all laughed at and criticized
but it saved American lives so are you
saved American lives with those
decisions and we in Tennessee we thank
you for that
we're opened up for business we're going
to the restaurants and businesses
running again we're ready to lead and we
appreciate your face plan we're
implementing it in Tennessee this thank
you for your leadership sir and we
appreciate it
and your governor's doing a great job
and you right now we banned people from
China coming in and they said oh but you
did allow people yeah there were
American citizens and they were allowed
in under very very strict rules and
regulations and quarantine and
everything else but we banned people and
a number of our leading doctors said
that would have that saved hundreds of
thousands of lives and that was in
January and I remember being in a room
with I think 21 people and I was the
only one that wanted to do that nobody
else wanted to do it they thought it was
they thought it was crazy it had never
been done before nothing like that had
ever been done before and now you watch
them the Democrats and the media say oh
I should have done it sooner
there was nobody even thought about it
and a month later you'd see Nancy Pelosi
and other people talking about this
disease is just nothing that's going to
spread over and she wanted to go and she
was actually in late in February she was
in Chinatown in San Francisco
celebrating because this disease is
going to be nothing so I don't I
understand that I mean she felt that and
I can understand it but for them to say
much early I actually banned Chinese
from coming in China from come
into our country it's a it's a just such
a political disgrace that they're able
to get away it's just like shifty chef
making the statement today to try and
save face when we have them called on
the papers on the documents and in about
nineteen different ways it's it's so bad
and so sad for our country thank you
very much mister president you you you
put that ban in place before they even
named the virus yeah you saved thank you
very much appreciate thank you mister
president Kelly Armstrong from North
Dakota we're an Ag in energy state so
we've been uniquely hit on a lot of this
stuff but I'd like to say thank you for
standing standing so tough with Saudi
Arabia that was a huge deal for our oil
producers obviously you've been great
for agriculture but thank you especially
for your statement yesterday in support
of cattle ranchers sometimes they get
lost in the mix and they've been getting
hit pretty hard right now so we really
appreciate that and then just you get
this economy up and going and we'll do
what we do best and that's feed and fuel
the world and that demand is coming back
and you're up to 25 26 dollars a barrel
and a little bit more and you're gonna
save your energy industry really because
we're number one and Russia and Saudi
Arabia I got them together and they came
to a good conclusion for us and for them
and for everybody
and once the demand goes up it's gonna
be great for the energy industry so
thank you very much thank you sir Thank
You mr. president and echoing the thanks
if you had lost that election in 2016 we
would never have been energy independent
and it's been great for Texas it's been
great for America and I do want to
advise our media friends before they
write stories about how we didn't wear
masks and we didn't possibly socially
distance adequately that you saw to it
that we had tests and that nobody in
here has the coronavirus unless it's
somebody in the media so the only reason
we would wear masks is if we were trying
to
to ourselves from you in the media and
we're not scared of you so that's why we
can be here like this so thank you for
amazing job you've done and it is
amazing to see the hypocrisy oh you do a
travel ban like Mark said it saved lives
and they called you racist and then when
they realized you did the right thing
they said you should have done it
earlier and and perhaps they could have
noticed the need if they had not been
pursuing you know the the hoax that was
the impeachment and I know the speaker
has appointed this new committee to
investigate your handling of the
coronavirus and I've suggested they
ought to name that committee the
committee of oligarchs too unlike the
president or COO for short but that's
exactly what it is and the money Stephen
and Larry thank you for your work there
are a lot of people that are working for
companies today that would not be in my
district in East Texas and they wouldn't
be I've heard this week from some that
say they're getting threats that if they
had any capital they shouldn't have
taken the loan and they may be pursued
for criminals when they could not have
hired those people back if they had not
taken the loan so I hope that that will
be backed off a little bit because it
has put people to work that couldn't
otherwise but I'm optimistic and I
wouldn't be if you weren't president so
thank you for the work that you do and
you've been a great help and if we
didn't win the election we wouldn't have
found out all of the corrupt practices
and everything no place at the top of
the FBI with dirty cops and all of the
things that we found out about other
people and other agencies that are
equally as important all of this we we
went on drain the swamp and that's what
we're doing but nobody ever told me this
WAMP was going to be this this vicious
or this deep and we're doing it could I
make a suggestion on the justice area
and I know that with the Democrats in
charge some of the most important
reforms may not happen but the FBI is
the only law enforcement entity I'm
aware of that has not even come into the
twentieth century not even asking them
to come into the 21st everybody else
does videotapes and audio tapes and the
FBI interviews witnesses and goes back
and records their own notes of what they
want to say a witness said and then it's
easily changed and we need to bring them
into the 20 20th century where they
start at least doing some audio
recording so they can't change them so
that's one of the lessons we've seen
from what's happened in their effort to
create a coupe and not only do they not
record but they write their notes and
then when the notes are bad for them
they go and change them months later
this is a corrupt deal that's been going
on and we caught him called and now we
have to see what happens but Bill Barr
has done a great job he's a strong guy
and he's done a great job and not easy
he's fighting a lot of fights but he
really has been great and we appreciate
it but you're right about that I said -
I'd like to hear a tape of what the
interview was so they said well no was
just and they write it out like scribble
yeah it's crazy and then they change it
and they change signatures they change
everything so we don't have the old one
it's one of the most incredible things
yeah thank you very much thank you [ __ ]
I just want to thank everybody in this
room for the past three and a half years
for supporting our president and the
administration and everything you've
done this man goes 1820 hours a day as
many of you know he's the most
transparent president in history he's
the most accessible - there's nobody in
this room that can't call or get through
to them mornings evenings big day but we
love you all and thank you so much on
behalf of everybody here in the White
House
for everything that you've done
supporting our president means the world
thank you
and what a job he's done too right mark
he's been amazing and he does it himself
I remember when I was running crooked
Hillary had 28 people I had Dan and Dan
blew them away it wasn't even a contest
and we have now I guess six different
sites platforms and we have numbers that
these people don't have they don't even
come close to it so when they write
false stories we can go around them and
it's very important to be who need to
who needs it I wish we didn't need it
but unfortunately we have to do that we
have to have that because we don't get
an honest press please I'll tell you
gates you'd you've been something he's
he's out there Devin right he's out
there fighting
thank you Matt your your team is here
we're ready to work and we are inspired
by our president I have observed your
willingness to work with anyone
I saw the Democrat governor of New
Jersey categorized the administration's
response as extremely responsive I've
noted on our calls that our Democrat
colleagues in the house like Tom Suozzi
and Jimmy Panetta have made
contributions reflected in the great
work that Jared is done on testing and
the Secretary minuchin is done and that
the chief has done as well but I have to
say mr. president I'm deeply concerned
about what we're seeing from the
Democratic leadership because in the
last several days they have been caught
in a terrible lie not only was there no
collusion we not now know that the
leaders of the Democratic Party knew
that there was no collusion at the
beginning and willingly lied to the
American people anyway not only see that
they're reverting to their old playbook
as we want to work together to provide
provision to our people and take good
ideas no matter where they come from
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer just want
to set up new committees to investigate
rather than working together I know that
even before being president you talked
about the importance of the president
being a great cheerleader for our
country and for our economy I know and I
know in the jobs report today we can see
that even the people who
have been furloughed or her on
unemployment now they're optimistic that
this is the team that will bring America
back what advice would you give us to
try to have our Democrat leadership
behave more like the governors you've
worked with and some of the
rank-and-file colleagues who've made
helpful suggestions rather than just
reverting to their hatred and their lies
to cover their tracks for their last
settle eyes I think they've been doing
it so long and gotten away with it for
so long long prior to us and they had
that eight years the Obama eight years
that have been absolutely terrible if
you look at the Justice Department or
what's taking place you look at the FBI
and what's taking place and frankly
prior to that a lot of bad things went
on all we can do is keep winning and if
we keep winning eventually they're going
to come around one way or the other may
not be in that form may not be them
because I'm not sure that you could do
that with them tremendous dishonesty
from Schiff and from others and they
know it's going on they know these are
not stupid people they know was a hoax
they know better than anybody in this
room it was a hoax they set it up
they're not aggrieved - I watched shift
shift II shift nine inches around the
neck and I watch this guy uses the
world's smallest colorant but I watched
him
I guess this morning talking about it he
acts so aggrieved so aggrieved
he knows it was there he got caught and
not only caught if he weren't in the
halls of Congress he'd be in jail
because he made up phony stories and
phony speeches and phony everything
everything was phony he's a sick man
he's really a sick man he's a corrupt
politician so I wouldn't count on
somebody like him but I think overall we
have some really good support I've had
great support from Democrat governors I
would say almost all almost all and in
some cases are lucky Andrew Cuomo the
other day said that I we have done a
phenomenal job
that's a nice statement phenomenal
that's a good word it's true but we've
had great support and a gavin newsom the
same thing he said something the
equivalent of that
so we can work with them but I think
this group is perhaps beyond repair
they're sick there's something wrong
with them well I have to before I
introduce you I have to say so we had
all of the great NCAA teams here
just prior to kovat otherwise they
wouldn't have been able to come but we
had all of the teams and one of the
teams was the top wrestling wrestlers in
the country all the champions NCAA
wrestlers and I saw him and I
immediately knew as a wrestling I could
see what's in a little action going over
those years and the muscles were coming
out of the shirts that I could see by
the jaw line and I walked up with Jim
Jordan and they didn't give a damn about
the president they said that's Jim
Jordan you don't know what a great
wrestling NCAA champion and a great
wrestler and they saw him those
wrestlers saw this guy and they said
sorry president I got to say hello to
him first right so Jim Jordan and he is
he's a champ he's a winner he knows how
to win the exact same time that we learn
what we did about general Flynn the
exact same time we learned that there
was absolutely no basis for the entire
Muller Russia investigation at the FBI
did that very time Nancy Pelosi sets up
the Select Committee to come after you
again
and so we just need to understand guys
that they're never gonna stop but in
spite of that relentless attack we've
seen from that mr. president we
appreciate your leadership we appreciate
your your entire team's leadership
getting things done for the American
people and I think is as Dan said I
appreciate your work ethic I know how
hard you work for the American people I
mean I know I know how our meadows where
he should return my calls all the time
now
I know he's working 15 hours 18 hours a
days you're working you're working even
more so thank you for doing all the
people in the fourth District of Ohio
appreciated the people around the
country have preciate it and we just
need to keep it up and we'll have the
great American comeback happening real
soon
right but I am here at gym I looked at
this competitive and I think about it I
see she's setting up an oversight
committee and I'm getting I'm getting
called by other countries saying what a
great job we're doing
could we have some help sir with testing
your tests are better than our tests at
the best tests and the more we have the
best tests in the world with the most us
so could we get ventilators is there any
way our people are dying could we get
ventilated everything and they set up an
oversight committee about the job we're
doing when she a month later was in
Chinatown dancing as I said it's a
disgrace
what's even more of a disgrace is take a
look at the people of the committee
they're the greatest Trump haters in
history Maxine Waters every one of them
is his people that were screaming
impeach before even announced running
now I keep it when I say that because
I'll say that's not true but pretty
close pretty close you know if I say
that they'll say that's not true
they don't understand sarcasm in the
press but I will say you look at some of
the people in that committee everyone is
a total kill and it's a disgrace it's a
disgrace that they could do a thing like
that and here we go again here we go
again but we beat them and we've been
beating them for a long time and they
they cannot accept it they cannot accept
it that's why it's interesting I can
work with the governors and we're doing
it really well and they're saying great
things about me and the job we're all
doing but you can't work with these
people I think this stone called crazy
anyway thank you Jim very much Kevin how
about a little recap as to how you think
we're going to do in that next year
coming up
you know I think it's fitting that the
members of Congress thank you for coming
back that you would be meeting and
working to make me found me better
precisely today which was about the
worst job support ever and that was
something that we've been telling people
was done right but because you took the
step to save lives just slow the economy
down but there was a silver lining in
the report today ladies and gentlemen
that was really interesting to us and
the president I talked about last night
in the Oval that almost everybody who
have a increase in unemployment in the
report today said they expect to go back
to work within six months and now if
that happens then what will have
happened is something historic that we
would have experienced the biggest shot
in the history of the world just about I
think short short of perhaps World War
and recovered quickly and I think that
if we did that sir it's going to be
because the economy was so strong in
January that people have been able to
withstand this and because the policies
that you all work together to adopt
built the bridge to the other store and
at the same time we would have saved
millions of lives because ultimately
that's what we did this for but I heard
that statement from you and some others
yesterday that almost everybody expects
to be back to work shortly that's very
unusual usually when you have something
like this they never expect to get a job
again so that's a great thing thank you
a good point thank you very much Jim mr.
president thank you Lee House
Republicans are here in Washington DC to
work we want to deliver for the American
people and we're honored to be here
today and hopefully the speaker calls us
back into session at the beginning of
next week we'll see we should have been
here this week the Senate's what was
here in Washington DC but what is she
doing where is she what's going on you
know I actually think that she's just
trying to consolidate more power in her
own gavel she likes the feeling of that
gavel in her hand she knows that the
grip is being loosened and come January
of 2021 she's going to have to hand it
over to Kevin McCarthy and in the
time she is trying to consolidate as
much power as you can and when she
brings her House Democrats to Washington
and there's a process where we're able
to participate in crafting legislation
she won't be able to dictate as much of
her obstructionist radical agenda that
appeases an enraged liberal base
[Music]
this is 7th Street in Belleville
Johannesburg usually one of the city's
most popular places to come socialize
dance drink and smoke this is seventh
Street in Belleville Johannesburg
usually one of the city's most popular
places to come socialize dance drink and
smoke this is seventh Street in Mobile
Johannesburg usually one of the city's
most this conversation I saw them with
you those veterans calling out to you
from that backdrop like they were 18 or
19 years old again
they just wanted a moment to share with
their president just to get a thumbs up
back they were there were little kids
even though they saved the world and I
want to thank you not just for this is
7th Street in Belleville Johannesburg
usually one of the city this is 7th
Street in Belleville Johannesburg
usually one of the city's most popular
places to come socialize
dance drink and smoke but for well over
a month not a single beer this is 7th
Street in Melville Johannesburg usually
one of the city's most popular places to
come to socialize dance drink and smoke
but for well over a month not a single
barrel pack of cigarettes has been sold
here legally anyway the prohibition on
alcohol and cigarettes here is part of
the raft of restrictions on consumers
into curbing the spread of coronavirus
South African government in justifying
its decision frame drinking as an
impediment to social distancing and also
point to its links to risky behavior
domestic abuse accidents and violent gin
closely and you know they understand to
have a deal hopefully they're gonna keep
the deal we'll see they made in may not
wait to find out well no soon
[Music]
[Music]
Chinn closely and you know they
understand have a deal hopefully they're
going to keep the deal we'll see they
made in may not wait to find out we'll
know soon chain closely and you know
they understand have a deal hopefully
they're going to keep the deal we'll see
they may they may not where to find out
we'll know soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's important for us to know that even
if the study isn't successful that we
learn from it because we want to have a
vaccine
[Music]
I also thought it'd be really
interesting experience to see the
patient perspective for the clinical
trial at some point a few tribal kingdom
perhaps on my research progress to a
clinical trial so I say we wanted to see
what that would be like as well
[Music]
this trial has expanded to many many
people and so now they're giving daily
temperature checks and daily symptoms
sort of diary it's uploaded every
evening so that the study can know
what's happening for the patients they
are very interested in a scientific
analysis of negative acts can actually
then follow it potentially the immune
response whether or not you have an
antibodies that we protective against it
and they can do all the fancy blood work
for that
[Music]
I think a vaccine is the safest way to
develop a herd immunity response that we
can therefore protect our friends and
family
and the people in scree
[Music]
[Music]
we're contacted by physicians who
alerted us to the importance of being
able to use this device potentially to
measure coughing and respiratory
activity and also temperature from this
region of the body
[Music]
[Music]